[Musique]
la légende raconte qu'un jeune papetier
fut envoyé en espion en angleterre et
rapporta à de lui les secrets des plus
beau papier vélin et vergers anglais
alpha sur glace et en 1875 démarrer
lusine créée par une famille d'imprimeur
bisontin des 1900 près de 500 employés
travaillent état de vue à laitages une
escouade de femmes étaient chargés de
préparer une partie de la matière
première
ce qu'on appelait dans l'argot de papier
la chiffonnerie c'est dans cet atelier
la queue ont déchiré les feuilles les
chemises on enlever les boutons l'école
en zinc tout ce qui est étranger pour
faire du papier et de triage et puis
ensuite je suis fonds étaient lacérés en
bourse vous pouvoir le mieux de passer à
la même en ce début de xxème siècle
l'usiné était devenu le village ou
inversement la papeterie rythmait la vie
des habitants de villages tourner autour
du papier un gauche à trois ans ils
étaient propres n'étaient dans une
garderie c'était une employée de la
papeterie qui le gars à qui les gardait
quand il avait 5 ans ilan à l'école
primaire ils sortent à 14 ans il est
épris d'office bon pas bon petit grand
unités prix de la papeterie
il se sent petit carrière mikati cassé
sa pipe c'est telle usine qu'ils elles
se recueille
et puis avec le cheval est pile
corbillard qui l'emmenait à sa dernière
demeure
lusine s'occupe de tout
dans les années 60 la crise s'invite
dans l'industrie du papier
après la fermeture de l usine de jeunes
en 1965 c'est le tour de celle de sa
voyant 75 puis le couperet tombe sur de
vue en 1977 les mains de les coûts
d'énergie ayant augmenté certains
nombres de papeterie qui était rentable
à l'époque le sont devenus largement
déficitaire avec la vie dans ses murs
lusine a perdu ses machines et puis sa
dignité
délaissée elle a fini par se dégrader au
point de menacer de tomber aujourd'hui
une partie privée est en passe de
devenir un tas de pierres l'autre côté
propriété municipale vit encore sous
perfusion
la charpente était fortement endommagé
les tuiles cassées donc il fallait
sauver le bâtiment
on a investi en 2015 et en 2016
des sommes quand même assez importante
de l'ordre de 200 mille euros afin de
mettre ce bâtiment à l'abri pour
finaliser les travaux d'urgence d'autres
interventions seront nécessaires un
financement participatif a été lancée
mais manque encore de généreux donateurs
la phase de travaux qui en cas envisagé
avec 97 milles euros pour refaire la
toiture et là vous en avez combien
premier 600 noms manque un peu il en
manque un peu alors après la commune des
deux lui obtient aussi des financements
de son côté des subventions un mail à la
souscription pour le moment
effectivement est à 3600 je vous cache
pas que c'est un petit peu des ans
pour claude lancelot qui a passé 25 ans
de sa vie dans l' usine entre 1952 et sa
fermeture en 1977 voir disparaître cet
endroit qui a tant compté dans la vie de
sa famille est un crève coeur
quand j'étais gamin j'allais à la pêche
ou me baigner ou je savais qu'à la
deuxième fenêtre et avait ma grand mère
on voyait qu'elle est assez d'accord
et chaque fois que je passe devant cette
fenêtre sans y pense on passait nos
journées sur ce barrage c'est là que
j'ai appris un avion s'est elle un lieu
de vacances par excellence
pour assurer son avenir plus qu'un
projet mais carter c'est d'une véritable
lettre d'engagement dont tu as besoin du
ciel